an extraordinary discovery has been made
in the u.s state of north dakota a
fossil of a dinosaur leg stunningly
preserved
but scientists think the dinosaur was
killed on the very day a giant asteroid
struck the earth 66 million years ago
which of course ended the reign of the
dinosaurs and began the rise of mammals
on our planet well joining me now is
professor phil manning the director of
the interdisciplinary center for ancient
life at the university of manchester
who's been working on this discovery for
eight years uh really great to talk to
you professor manning um
so
we've got a picture of the dinosaur leg
but my understanding is that it's
actually
fish that were also in that dinosaur
area uh and and what is in those fish's
gills that is the key thing is that
right
yes a couple of years ago we published a
paper which
narrowed down the age of the site um to
link with the impact event that and of
the asian dinosaurs
so well that that was a slam dunk loving
the
excuse me
the data that was
coming out of this particular site and
one of the most exciting things uh about
this is that it's all we can't get
better than fish fish interacting with
ejector from the actual impact event how
amazing but then robert and the team
last summer when they were excavating we
had a camera crew out with us so you can
actually see it coming out of this this
layer of rock these remarkable remains
of what is effectively a mummified
dinosaur where the skin is beautifully
preserved as impressions over the leg
and around the bones and i've never seen
anything quite as beautiful
as this particular dinosaurs like in my
life
wow
and
it is beautiful nevertheless but the
thing that that
people are focusing on is the dating of
it and the fact that
you're able to date it so accurately how
are you able to do that well if you can
imagine if something the size of mount
everest smashes into the earth at 60 000
miles per hour it tends to do a lot a
lot of damage and it vaporizes cubic
miles of earth's crust and as it's
blasted into the atmosphere it cools
down rapidly into these little droplets
of glass we call microspherules these
were blasted around the planet and they
landed at the tannis site just as a
shockwave was hitting the site from the
impact event so we've got a mixture of
impact ejector as it was raining down
from the heavens into this this this
ecosystem of the hell creek formation
and it's encapsulated in this one and a
half meter thick deposit and the top of
it is got this very distinctive chemical
signature of an element called iridium
which is a platinum group element and
that is what nails the actual date of
this particular package of sediment so
we've got ejecta being blasted
throughout this one and a half meter
depth of sediment and on top of it
you've got the iridium anomaly that
dates it perfectly to be on the last day
of the dinosaurs
and how did it feel when you realized
that that was the actual date you were
looking at and that you actually had
this
crucial bit of information
utterly gobsmacked
i mean you can't dream of finding such
remarkable legalities anywhere on the
planet and
the students working on this robert
department who's doing done some amazing
field work is a very very thorough
scientist and it's a pleasure working
with him in fact you can see his
trousers just there in the picture
but robert has done some phenomenal work
on this and it's through his tenacity
and his
careful nature of picking through this
deposit that we've been able to sort of
retell this story and it's and it's
wonderful as a professor i learned so
much from my students and it's a
pleasure to see a student doing so well
and and we've got all this fantastic
footage there's going to be a
documentary broadcast about it but it
it's also important to get it peer
reviewed isn't it how is that all going
well we've had a peer review paper and
genius a couple of years ago where we
had the dating of the site and
everything was constrained that was
really good we had a paper a few months
ago actually in nature scientific
reports which dates the impact event of
just about spring to early summer time
there are papers coming out also we've
got two abstracts which are coming out
um in three weeks time at the european
uh geological union meeting in indiana
and we then robert was presenting on
this at nasa last night in a colloquium
lecture so we're pushing the data out as
much as we can in as multiple formats as
we can the nice thing is the dating has
been done the site is is well and truly
uh established as being a kpg boundary
site
what's new is the fact we're getting
dinosaur remains out of there thankfully
you know you see a mini it's a mini you
see a land rover it's a land rover you
see a chicken it's a chicken
this is a dinosaur and i can see it's a
dinosaur sometimes you don't need
statistics to show that it's a dinosaur
and in this case there there was a film
crew filming as we were excavating the
site telling the already published story
on the date so now they got an extra
bonus of a rather beautiful dinosaur
well it's fantastic
that you are so excited about it and
jolly well done for being involved in
this research professor phil manning
thanks so much for joining us
thank you